joining us now one of the top pass
rushers in the 2020 draft class he's
george's aziz
ogilari aziz welcome to the program how
are you i'm doing good how about you
appreciate it
doing great great to talk to you always
great to talk to the guys who are
getting ready to have
their lives change in a dramatic way
here we are 16 days out from the first
round of the draft
what kind of emotions and thoughts and
ideas go through your head as you get
closer and closer
and finding out what your future is
going to be yeah i'm just excited i'm
just ready and i'm just we
just can't wait for the moment really
where will you be
when the draft starts uh i would be
we have so we have this like spot that
i'll be using is over in fayetteville
that is where i'll be as it will be a
house
so uh you you've had a great career
at georgia one of the reasons why you're
regarded as one of the top pass rushers
in the class
what's your proudest moment when you
reflect on the time
that you're a bulldog what stands out
yeah i'll just say just playing with my
brothers
see my teammates just being there every
day just working every day working hard
just just working for that end goal just
to win
win games win championships we we didn't
get to win the national
championship we'll go to it but we got
opportunity playing great bowl games
like the peach bowl sugar bowl
and just winning those big bowl games
the new year six balls was just big
it was just fun time with my teammates
really is there a game or a moment that
stands out to you aziz is something that
that was more significant than any
others at georgia
yeah the the last game actually the last
game
at the peach bowl against cincinnati it
was it was different it was big
i came along huge in that game and it
was just the greatest it was a great
game
overall what did it mean to you to be a
team captain as a freshman
well it just meant a lot just knowing
that the guys believe and trusting me as
a young
guy she's doing everything in the right
way and just
having that just knowing that you could
be counted on as a young guy
what's your leadership style are you
vocal or do you lead by example or some
of both
i'm a more lead by example type of guy
one thing that i've seen that you do
which creates a very good example for
people like me
you keep your area very clean how did
you become a guy who likes everything
clean and in order definitely uh just
always growing up i always been that
type
of guy just to be clean and neat and
organized everything i do
is a must for me because it just makes
my life easier and everything
goes smoothly when everything is neat
clean and organized
and that's the way i love it that's the
way i like it now your brother bj at lsu
how much is he like that because if he's
not i'm sure that
has to get a little aggravating you want
things a certain way and he may not care
nah he's like that too definitely we're
both like that just growing up you know
the same household
so it's just part of it's part of us now
and it's just with us and we're going to
keep it with us
forever so he's like that too aziz when
i watch film of your time at georgia i
see that number 13 which obviously is a
number that that
you won't be able to wear at the nfl
level but how did you end up in number
13
in college yeah so uh i just
they they had a list of numbers to
choose and i just was like let me just
go with one three
uh might as well just go without me it
was a cool number for me and i was like
all right i'm gonna just rock rock with
it
and see what happens you know it's funny
we were talking about this earlier today
because today is april the 13th
and it's not friday the 13th but it's
still the 13th and some people are
freaked out about it
you clearly have no qualms about 13. nah
nah i don't you fight into 13 now i
don't
what what number do you want to wear at
the next level um
any any knee line i saw back in number
probably 58
99 or 91 or 51 one of those
probably you said 58 first von miller's
number is that the guy that you're still
patting yourself after
definitely big time for sure what things
about his game have you tried to
incorporate into yours
just uh just being versatile and
everything he could do everything on the
field
at the end position he could drop him
coverage uh
rush the passer you know stop the run
just make different
impact plays force fumble he gets sacks
always force fumbles
just change game changing moments and
game game changing plays that he
make it i just see myself just doing
that and the way he played the way he'd
been the way he used his hands he's just
he's a different athlete different do
you watch
his film and try to try to emulate the
things that he does to
to help your own game improve yes sir
definitely i do just watching some of
his film and taking it out to the field
on saturday and that
was definitely big for me just seeing
because the guys like going guests are
huge and big just like the guys he going
against definitely so
just taking the little things and using
the things that he used to my advantage
on saturday helped me out a lot what
would you say you do
best what's your best attribute on
football field
well i'll say just being able just being
a version just being versatile being
able to rush the passer
stopping the run just peel i could peel
backs out the backfield like a cover so
it was just like
those three things really just big in my
game the best things i do
i've seen you in two point stance and
and then i've also seen kind of that
wide nun oh both hands on the ground do
you put both hands on the ground or do
you keep one a little bit off or you go
on four do you go three
i usually go i go three i go three when
i get off the ball
it makes it it's easier for me it's just
more smoother
when i'm in the three-point stance i can
run in track stance when i get off it
just makes it i get off this faster out
of three
what's your favorite pass rush move um
my favorite password move i call it the
long tube
with a long arm long arm with a snap a
club with a club
a long arm with a club so what do you do
so i'm basically just getting off on the
ball
and i'm sticking my long arm with the
tackle chest or whatever
just just to get his hands i'm trying to
get his hand because i go by if you beat
the hands you beat the man
so if i stick that long he's gonna have
to give me something he's just not gonna
just let me just stick his my arm in his
chest
he's gonna bring his hands and once you
give me his hands that's when i go with
the club
and i'm going right behind him with the
rip at the end different air up
you go around to the outside then right
outside yeah but i've seen you go inside
i've seen you with the power move
is this part of the chess match where
you'll use different moves based upon
what you think the offensive lineman's
ready for
definitely yes sir your kids you can't
give them everything
at the end of the game you got to uh
just set up your rushes as the game go
on
and then you know at that time the
moment you know when to just boom
just put that power on him when he's
least expecting it and you right at the
quarterback
he's like a chess not checking so let's
just take your time with it
and then boom once it comes boom he's
not expecting it
yeah at the quarterback different kind
of years the draft approaches there was
no scouting combine this year you had
your pro day workout you're allowed to
talk to as many teams
as you want and as want to talk to you
who have you heard from the most
via zoom or otherwise as we've gotten
closer to the draft
yeah so i've been talking to plenty of
teams like a whole bunch like
almost all of them so i've been like
back and forth zooms every day
daily like it's in my schedule every
single day it's been a boatload of teams
every single day just zooming with me
just trying to get to know me
how i play what what type of player i am
and just it's just been great just
creating those relationships meeting
those new coaches on
gm's head coaches just just building
that relationship and bond to
just to to draft day just wait to see
where i end up
what question have you gotten the most
uh just uh
i mean they basically just asked about
my growing up at home
how it was in georgia how i ended up at
georgia that's this one uh
just how like what do i prefer for three
three four
who do i compare myself to stuff like
that what do you prefer
four three or three four i may as well
ask you if everybody else is
yeah uh basically uh i could do both
because at georgia we did both so
whatever it is i'm good with it and i
can play at a high level
with either formation either either one
i'm cool three four four three
i could play it because that's why
georgia was great for me we did both
and we have plenty of time we did both a
lot so i'm comfortable with either one
so who's the toughest guy you've faced
in college
toughest guy i've faced the team or the
just person the player the guy the guy
that you had to deal with
uh the guy that had to deal with i'll
say
uh i'll say i said i'd probably say alex
alex leatherwood from alabama
she's probably the best guy face who's
the guy you're looking forward
to facing at the next level the next
level definitely uh
i probably said i'll say
hmm this is tough i mean this is a whole
bunch of great players at the next level
so
any any of them to be honest really just
to be able to be on that stage would be
big for me
just to be out there competing with the
best of the best you know i'm in the
best league so the best of the best
is every sunday is a competition you
know you're gonna get the best from them
and i'm gonna give you the best so
anyone really is there any one
quarterback you have in mind that you
can't wait to get your hands on
uh uh i mean probably tom brady
but he gets the ball out so fast that
you never probably won't be able to get
someone but
uh i don't i don't know we'll see i
don't know hey you gotta be careful that
too you never know which guy's gonna end
up being your teammate
the way this song is do you have
and i've talked to different guys about
this over the years one of the things
guys do they get on madden
they make the player of themselves and
they check out different uniforms and
see how they look have you done anything
like that to see
see where azizojalari is going to look
best in an nfl uniform
no i actually have it i haven't really
done when i usually play matter i
usually just play like online
head-to-head
or you might play against my friends but
that's it i ain't really i ain't make no
player or nothing
so i don't know do you have an idea of
the range you know when the window is
going to open
and when you expect it to to be closed
by where you're going to be drafted a
high and a low
um i really don't have no range because
i really i really don't know i'm not
going to lie i'm not
i just i pray somewhere in the first
round definitely for sure
that would be a blessing for sure so
we'll see you on the 29th
you had that torn acl in high school
that doesn't happen very often to high
school athletes what was the hardest
part
of getting yourself back to 100 because
i assume a lot of what you have to do is
stay within the boundaries of the rehab
and when you're young you want to do
everything and it's got to be
frustrating
to just do the things you're supposed to
do and nothing else yeah so
coming in i was a freshman you know i
always wanted to play as a freshman but
and everything but the dream it was
different everything for me was
different because i came in with the
knee
and so it was just like yeah i gotta do
this i gotta i gotta get back healthy
that was the main focus for me to just
get back healthy
and just know my opportunity would come
and i just kept getting my head down
kept working every single day i just
knew
that the day was gonna come the
opportunity i was gonna be blessed
opportunity to play here in georgia
one day and i just kept working every
single day just keeping the main thing
the main thing
just making sure you get back healthy
that's my main thing just to get back
healthy
and i know everything will play this
part who's better pass pressure you're
your brother
i say me i mean what do you say
all right you probably say him but
we got that competitive mindset every
single with everything we do but
i'll say me i'll say me he's still
learning and
i'm not him too but you ran that 463
in the 40 your pro day how did that fit
with what you would hope to do faster
slower or right where you wanted to be i
said i could hit
i feel like it could have been faster
for sure probably in a
four or five range for sure low four
fives for sure i feel like i could have
been faster
if i had to clean up a little more a
little bit of techniques my starts that
have been
way faster you got a great family story
and a rich history your grandfather
prince twin
seven seven from nigeria a nigerian
prince i know as of a few years ago you
hadn't been to nigeria have you been
there yet
if not when are you planning on going no
i haven't been there yet but definitely
will
definitely be go there for sure i'll
definitely
be there one time so soon very soon
actually
whenever i get it off time ready free
time i definitely
want to plan a trip there for sure with
my family definitely
one thing that i saw that really
resonated with me the thing that your
grandfather said to you when you were 10
years old as these you were quiet you
were going somewhere you're going to be
somebody what kind of an impact
did that have on you at that age what
kind of an impact does it have on you
still today
yeah definitely man this big is a big
impact on me just believing in him
and myself just knowing that people
believe in you
your loved ones and just knowing that
they see it they didn't send it they
didn't saw it already and just kept
believing in me
and now the moment is coming here and
i'm just ready for it and i just been
praying and just
just keeping my faith in god and
everything is where everything's working
out for me well and it's just i'm just
thankful
for sure now you're 6'3 how tall is your
brother bj
he's about 6 30. the same height i saw a
picture of you with your parents
unless you were standing on a box you're
a lot taller than them
how's that happen oh yeah
i'm definitely way taller but our
grandparents are definitely tall so
we probably we get it from them on that
side my mom's side for sure
when you are with your brother and it's
time for a picture which guy gets up on
his tiptoes
[Laughter]
i'm a little taller than him by a little
bit but he's going to probably pass me
so you're the one that gets on your toes
no i'm already you know
that's great stuff hey aziz we wish you
all the best congratulations
on your career so far we can't wait to
see what happens for you coming up
in the draft and we look forward to
seeing you blossom and flourish as an
nfl player congratulations on all your
success and all the best moving forward
hope to talk to you again real soon
thank you very much thanks for having me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports